yeah the software is telling me that I'm
life but especially after the experience
of the last week where nothing really
get to work at the beginning of it I'm
totally unsure so give me a brief info
if I'm really live on the air yep okay
someone's telling me live that's good so
let's see if I can get some cool
five-minute games in I'm sitting on a
pretty high rating so it the live
session here will be a bit dangerous for
my rating either I fear ok I'm going to
make this a little bit bigger the shed
window I'm going to answer to the chat
but I try to look at it more between the
games so that during clay I'm kind of
more focused on on the actual game um um
I don't get a game now what is this hmm
why am I not getting a game Oh already
clicked that right yeah that's kind of a
long wait unusual
huh okay yeah are you guys any any
questions oh now I get again let's see
against deranged from the UK what is
this guy to 450 a time that's a high
rating so I get them uh-huh yeah this is
getting popular the now it is call to
the rarest of a check ok I'm going to
play in a solid fashion giving me some
space for the bishop hmm ok maybe that
wasn't necessary really now that I think
of it ok he's trading them yeah I got a
question how was my trip to Hamburg um
ok it was ok i am been to hamburg and
went to work a little bit for a
competitor of icc so i'm not going to
tell you much about that it's really not
very appropriate to do that yet life
live broadcast him it was a good
experience though it was much lots of
work but but good good to do and i can
also tell you that there will also be
some more content on the way that I'm
going to produce for icc so it's just
around the corn on that same ok what
about threatening checkmate let's rent
check wit we all like to do that ok b3 I
had some add some squares 93 so when we
goin should be six I guess and then a5
a4
it looks okay for me I think I'm in the
center this is kind of worrisome but
well I don't know is he going to really
get somewhere g5 and g6 going to happen
I can go to h5 though ok i'm going to
try that a5 a4 i know it's going back
interesting i have to get out of the
possible those possible I a no es dead
with the tempo ah interesting yeah i was
thinking night h5 attacking the the
bishop the abbot of course now i don't
have this temple move aunty sg6 which is
a bit awkward hmm ok I did not expect
that move but it's not bad of course ng6
coming home that's not looking good them
hmm who that's not looking good yeah I'm
worse whatever you whatever you play a
museum see take see at night b5 and
night maybe night takes I don't know it
looks it looks awkward you can just take
age 60 m which is good now just just GTX
h6 is good yeah this also might be good
but here i can castle maybe maybe i can
survive castling hmm i don't know it
looks very very shaky if you take the f7
i can at least recapture eric g one
simply for an attack the bad thing is
that a 4s
not threatening very much it really
isn't it is threatening bishop age 6 cm
a for Bishop age 6 10 a 4 tick ctx
that's not really really great ideas
Queen g6 possibly coming up yeah but
okay I cannot just cannot just sit
around i rather give him this message 6
poem for the edge phone it's probably
never enough but still so Queen g6 is
coming I should at least prevent that um
he has Bishop g7 possibly but okay
nothing that I can do about it trying to
take c3m maybe night c4 as a threat now
yeah maybe night c forum for made on b2
and if he takes Bishop takes its words
anyway I wonder maybe it can just take
g7 and crash through Bishop takes rook
takes rook takes king cake groups you
won't check and so it might be might be
just winning
might be Bishop g7 can I go nite see for
now not sure yeah but let's see what
he's doing come on i'm totally down on
time here it's a very critical position
but he can probably just play a move
like rock g2 we are covering the second
rank and kind of asking me what what am
I going to do next and this is not easy
to answer this question okay he went for
them for the kill okay so can I take on
c3 or not if I do that what is his move
Bishop b5 check or bishop h6 check Jim
probably probably just wins night see
forever hmm i don't know i'm probably
losing but let's just speculate here a
bit if he gave us Bishop b5 check our
play King evade and I'm not sure he
mates me I'm suddenly lost yeah but
let's try them okay let's at least an
easy move Queen B to mate is the idea
if he goes rook g2 I play rook a for
threatening look before check their this
isn't some counter player at least a
little bit I'm not sure maybe I'm still
losing directly but I don't see it at
the moment um like rook g8 or something
I can't even play King e7 and I can
probably also take the rook hell what is
he doing now not sure oh that set i did
not see at all it's probably not a bad
mood so I'm going ok I'm going to take
it and now ok for rookie three I mean
activating the rook and I can take on f3
with the other look that gets kind of
kind of strange if I can see if I check
them I'm threatening queen before if he
moves the Queen what a weird position
look have one yes I just I just saw it
this is some tricky move hmm i don't
have a check here somewhere maybe here
for possible Queen at five I didn't see
that one coming r is Queen a three I
didn't see that coming Queen g3 ok give
the check
okay try to play actively him try to use
the C porn I checked I to check and I to
check that's the big issue why it's a
check that's awful that was really bad I
was really out of the woods mostly I
think okay he went there okay I need to
pre move them a key reasons I kind of I
kind of mm-hmm I don't I think I horse
was out of it but at the end he got it
Queenie to Queenie to check what a bad
bad thing happening them yeah what the
weird weird game yeah I don't play with
increment because there is no increment
pool on a sec which might or might not
change in the future I like to play the
automated pool games because they they
give the best opposition and they are
yeah they are a little bit fairer I
think because they they don't allow for
people to decline challenges and so on
if they play they play they cannot touch
your challenge sometimes you have that
yeah people play against you in a
challenge system they win a game the
recognized oh that guy is really strong
and somewhere i go to win then they
don't play anymore and in the rating in
the pools here they cannot dodge the
thing if they have the game started it
is um going to go into going to be going
to be played that's good who's the
greatest player that never became world
champion this is probably a matter of
taste my personal opinion there would be
would be Rubenstein
but there may be there are maybe
different opinions there is some there
is always an argument to be made for
people like Karis but it's um I really
think that Rubenstein really at one
point in the in the before World War one
he was the best player for two or three
years and I don't think that this
applies to two caras or corn or any of
the other games or any of the other
people that are normally mentioned in
this regard okay so black here played a
quick c5 interesting hmm interesting 95
can I go 95 look-see 297 how weird is
that 95 Roxy 297 look beat you what kind
of position is that it's equal material
wise but my night only seven is strapped
hmm funny funny I can go to see six
okay let's do that I don't really
understand it and Tia while he has to
take the Queen having everything else is
kind of Kanna weird politics is just bad
for black and roe he has to take the
Queen so roop takes it two nite e7 look
be too and I thought knight c6 might be
quite good but this is a very very weird
position I don't really know what he's
thinking yes to take si tu NE way he
takes is strategically terrible and
Bishop takes lose the rook so I don't
know what is there to think about
strange always rootsy to losing or
something I don't see it possible 97
rook be too is there some great move
there I don't see it can I trap his rook
no I don't think so knight c6 and c5
ride f5 hmm I mean he really has to take
on c2 he takes is just not any good and
maybe he can take him maybe he can play
exam maybe then Jesus rg6 is not
possible he takes I just play Queen d1
threatening night f5 I don't see what he
does against that even g6 there's
possibly night f5 weird I don't
understand what he's thinking about as
well by the Schweitzer's writing that
yeah he really has to do that the other
stuff is terrible ok so now I have to go
to see six right there is another and
what the square and this is based on the
fact that on e5 we have nine f5 but it
still kind of strange this position so
I have my doubts really about this it
looks shaky so let's say he goes a six
what am I going to play then I don't
really know I don't really know maybe
Bishop f3 to support the night
hey six looks kind of normal and and at
the end he did play it so what about
this now can I go I cannot really go
anywhere with the night weird I was
thinking this is maybe a move just
protecting it and on castles I can do 97
at least and I cannot trap his bloody
rukon be two wheel it's really strange
okay so he just took their which is kind
of kind of comfortable in comparison
maybe I should take with the bishop
actually I don't know but this is a pen
and Bishop e7 as a move is 95 yeah that
was stupid going into 95 now okay I'm
going back to that wasn't good Bishop c7
was just losing losing and move for
absolutely nothing Jim at least I think
it's for nothing what is he doing now
though maybe I have I don't have that I
thought before maybe could be a trick
rook takes knight c6 okay so i think i'm
going to try to trade this this rook and
now maybe before is an idea to get a six
it's very equal ish but at least i have
more time this is kind of good so check
and then to a check on a six maybe you
can take on b3 for trades but at the end
I'm going to be a little bit more active
here with a rope coming on the 7th rank
and possibly Bishop c4
so what is this what is he going to do
rook c8 form activating the rook is down
on 20-something seconds right this is
kind of kind of funny so what am I going
to do I can take them I can just take
right if it checks me a FB should have
won what is this forum for Roxy to him
that's true well that's true actually
okay so he's going back now looks it too
hmm I have to check though one Roxy to
and I will probably win this on time but
I tried to still make good moves him oh
I did not really think about this so so
so greatly now he can go can do this but
I can still have the slightly better end
game went in terms of in case of that
him let's see I can enter with the king
or push the point i'll probably push the
pawn
okay I'm going to go b6 and now try to
come over with a king g4 it's not
helping I have to do it like that I mean
this is not a dead raw I can I can
really play this play the zone no no
this is I mean this is probably a draw
but you still have to have to play this
there's really no reason to to to make a
draw him and it is very dry though now
come on you cannot play like like a
total [ __ ] and then expect them together
draw in a not so clear and game okay so
next one I already had reasons to play
on with because of the beep on okay um
what do you think about making notes of
the moves while playing in a rapid
tournament hmm I don't know I never saw
that happen actually I don't know well
there are kind of kind of some questions
here let's have never ever played the
French defense and if yes why did you
stop playing I played it quite a lot
actually but I didn't have I didn't have
that great um I didn't have any great
results that was the first problem and I
noticed that in the French sometimes
what what has the tendency of getting in
a tag on my king I mean yeah sometimes
you have less space on the Kings side
they kind of attack you my king and i
didn't really am I didn't really like it
that that my king got under pressure
what to do they have a tournament in two
weeks if you really want to get your
game sharpened up for in two weeks you
should do some tactics really do some
takes and trying to get a fresh mind
that same okay playing deep black who is
this guy actually Carlos Garcia Palermo
yeah that's a no d6 in his 60s what do
you think is one area you want to prove
in your game my game yes I would really
love to be better at calculation many
other areas of my game arc really ok but
sometimes calculate real nonsense um
okay um there's a question I play
someone writes I play the cuse gambit q
GD exchange what been playing against
the NIMS 0 which is three NIM sir would
you suggest the II III and Nige et
cetera because positions can be similar
or Bishop b3 and Knight f3 hoping to get
an IQ p position well that's a very very
specific question um III 92 as some is
possible but it's a line that I
personally don't like so much because
it's kind of it is kind of what what how
can you call that it's very sluggish in
terms of development no no it's a GM is
Carlos Garcia Palermo this is a classic
GM a classic Jam he's an old-timer GM in
his 60s but still quite quite good he's
in height in the high 2400 you know was
how do you win against someone who keeps
exchanging everything yeah trying to if
they really want to exchange everything
try to offer them exchanges that that
are favorable for you sometimes they
really want to exchange everything
because they have no other idea how to
play a game and then the idea would be
to try to initiate exchanges that are ok
for you yeah it sounds very basic but
it's really the way to go you shouldn't
try to avoid every exchange but try to
maybe go for exchanges that you don't
mind yeah okay what is
opening in this game is really doing
nothing yet but I'm still not hugely
better anything i still like my position
though the double pawn is not a problem
and his be to proper born porn can be
can be an issue the night to a 492 d3
i'm comfortable here I like my position
but i'm not sure is however how to play
it concretely let's do this and try to
be quick and really a bit um ahead on
the head on the clock yeah i didn't
really answer the question about the
news oh I think in back comparison I
would play the e3 Bishop d3 and night a
three line the total main line I think
this is some this is more it is quicker
you have a quikr development down and
this is something that I usually prefer
but it's a lot of lot of it is am as a
matter of taste it's not a matter of
good or bad moves yeah this guy is
trading everything but okay what is he
doing here trying to play 93 okay I'm
going up with my king at least it can
never move the beep on due to Knight c3
check so is there any other question
let's see that's ok I have to play a
couple of moves here what is he going to
do though what is this idea 93 is from
you that idea right ok so maybe rook c8
trying to be annoying and see what he
does what is it that I can do here can I
do something active not much I can play
a look-see 5v5 but it's probably leading
nowhere
okay so Luke see one okay maybe I can
activate the king if he goes Luke see
one now that will be a terrible trade
okay I wonder yeah well okay night c5 is
a draw but that sets all of it that's
really not great I wonder if rooks
aphorism I can just play a3v three
nights III might be good for me but it's
difficult to do something here okay look
II one hmm see going to play e5 maybe
okay i'm getting a little bit of space
yeah okay its place in five but isn't
this kind of kind of tricky if i take
now here you can probably take on b5
though nap but it is still probably the
best best chance that i have okay so if
i take now it's leading nowhere but i
can give the check and what about this i
can take a three and it takes a five
right I don't have don't have anything
better than okay aight leads nowhere
I don't know maybe I should have just
taken a three maybe I should have just
taken but ok I don't think I I'm taking
a big risk here oh really ok it's not a
huge deal I was thinking that this is
not a good good trade but it probably is
ok for him can check chief I guess I go
to tea fire front trying to be active
Luke b5 rook c5a it is it is a draw no
matter how you how you play really check
jam you can even go King a for him no
it's wrong King a for I will play King
c5 maybe he will take ok he won't take
um chief always a bit of a weird move
actually I go here farooq f4 look aged 6
it is still a draw of course takes takes
each form
hmm takes takes each for King d4 I
cannot go there whom I was intending to
play to play rook at four but it's not
really working
now it's just a rumor can you do yeah
okay for you can trade he can just trade
forum for them and for the advanced
pawns h5 he might go g5 now I played
this to ambitiously I should have just
played some normal moves I try to do
something in this end game which wasn't
a good idea yeah I was just too too
ambitious I was just too ambitious in
this end game but farm and now i'm
sitting in this crap of a position okay
and now we can go rookie seven yeah no
no no no and he will see that no we
didn't see it now this is actually a
draw i think
I offering a draw he can try to win on
time but is very slow it is really just
the wrong yeah game drawn by repetition
Wow now I totally screwed that one up it
was a slightly better and game at the
start but then I I'll play myself with
the fight trying to do something that
was not there okay I'm probably and
there's a question about going to first
over the board chess tournament like a
tournament for beginners if there is
something like that um I'm not sure
beginner is a bit bit tough maybe but
there are tournaments and it depends
very much on where you are located
because the tournament scene in Europe
and and and the US for example is kind
of kind of different but there are often
local tournaments that are structures
into into groups yeah like there's a
like a top group which is open for
everybody which maybe is frequented by
players like like I am or there might be
a group for let's say people rated below
1500 or something and this is maybe the
the way you want to go yeah if you are
Spanish that's good because Spain has
many chess tournaments it's a far more
difficult to get a tournament in some
some other places Spain is a really
great forum for chess so you can be a
big letdown okay night a sixth is what
this guy played I think he's going for
night before and possibly Bishop to f5 I
wonder
yeah III is kind of lame but it is kind
of lame but I don't know what is best
here yeah if you enter the those kind of
lower rated category tournaments you
maybe um maybe we'll meet a couple of
junior players that's very likely okay
I'm playing a very very simple way here
with Bishop d3 yes Spain is some Spain
is good form four chairs in general
there are many many good events on all
of all levels let's say okay I'm just
going to play simple developing moves
and he's going to try to trade stuff
okay not much that I can do I still have
a decent position nothing terrible
happened
yeah I don't know I don't want to trade
I actually questioned my decision now of
going to e5 I don't want to trade down
yeah it might happen that you lose
against one of the kids but that's that
the way it is Fifi okay so the only
thing that I have going in for me is
that the special bond g7 is not doing
much I still like my position but it's
nothing really great I have to be have
to be objective there maybe I should
have played rugby one attacking the beep
on ok but that's not bad just looking at
the beep on and what is the main
difference between the caro-kann and the
French strategically hmm um yeah the
only thing that they have in common that
they are both openings that fixed on or
based on a light squared pawn placement
yeah II 65 or c65 are light squares but
they are really a bit different quite
quite a bit actually because in the
French you tend to get very the
positions are mostly really closed one
in the caro-kann you very often get half
open positions if you take on e4 in the
French you can take only four but that's
not the main feature of the position
very often you have this e 5 close
center however nowadays against the
CARICOM people play the e5 advanced
quite often and this is quite quite
comparable in terms of strategy em it's
also this the center young and dumb
they're not so far away from one another
even if the bishop is outside of the
chain um French is usually leading to a
little bit more and no
i feeI if i should say it like that Liam
to avoid more complex positions it's
often a little bit more complicated
while the caro-kann especially if white
is playing Knight c3 or 92 on move 3
tends to get a little bit more um let's
say a bit more this is a bit smoother
sometimes you know it's not so
complicated but it's not I'm not really
trying to judge the openings here just a
different kind of scenario okay we had
some traits in this game and now with B
5 i'm trying to do something here
against his pawns um yeah so am I going
to play 95 or not I can also play
neither be four which is interesting
maybe night before the chiro card is not
boring actually it's not that boring oh
I totally forgot that you can take
whoo-hoo that's a bad mistake on my part
the caro-kann is not not boring and it
really isn't because they mostly play I
mean you can play with long casts over
here you can have opposite color
opposite side castling for example quite
often in the main lines and in the
advanced variation is not boring at all
it's very sharp actually I don't know if
I'm playing this right here with Roxy
seven if you have problems with
converting positions it's very often do
too sloppy calculation because value you
feel like well I'm okay I did everything
all right but how do I actually win and
this is very often something that can
only be done with pure number crunching
yeah move by move by move of calculation
and very often you lose games at exactly
this point where you have to number
crunch things okay I'm speaking of that
I'm really not sure what this position
is fatigue b7 with the rook takes takes
a three I think I'm stopping the pawn
but takes takes a three hmm i might not
stop the porn a 395 a 4 mm how awkward
is that ok going to take
and see what I can do here is there any
way here to check night b96 check at
least are active okay 96 check is going
to d 8 down hmm ok still I'm going to
play that maybe I get in night c4 here
and sometimes I have checks in yeah I
can give him a ton of checks now at
least I come on you want to draw that's
kind of that's kind of lame in this
position you're just a pawn up buddy can
i play for win here I don't think so
really I came on okay it's just the
Blitz game I probably shouldn't do that
yeah that's not objectively right but
I'm trying I'm really just a pawn down
to be honest so not a good idea to try
to play for one may be here just try to
get b6
where's he going look after it gets kind
of oh he's giving me the rook so this
paid off but it was a very risky
decision to to continue okay let's see
and there is a recommendation um yeah
there is a recommendation for a book and
I I like the book actually someone
writes that they got a vigorous chest
opening repertoire for black this is an
opening about the Petrov defense and the
Petrov is an opening that is vastly
misunderstood I think it's very often
yeah it's very often described it very
boring and stuff like that um well there
are some lines and the Petrov that are
boring but not necessarily if both
players really want to fight you can you
can really play this in an aggressive
way so one is this actually I i recently
looked at that I think it is 95 here d 6
I forgot I forgotten the whole thing
or do I play this I don't know the black
thing in my shelf is a speaker system
yeah the Petrov the pet shop is not a
bad opening at all the advantage of it
as the black player is that the white
players don't get it so often because it
has such a it has such a boring
reputation that people don't play it but
there is no big reason not to play it
objectively speaking the only reason I
don't play the petrol is that it tends
to lead to very open positions it's
actually a technical opening a little
bit and I am actually I like positions
where I have some porn play where I can
play for porn breaks and things like
that and this is not happening in the
petrol very much the Petrov is good for
people who want open positions with
calculation and I rather have a position
that is more in in a strategic nature
yeah something that is more um yeah more
closely at same okay I'm trying to trade
something here by the way this is a very
strong opponent reviso he's a GM okoro
tilia is the name he's about two of two
thousand five hundred eighty or
something like that so pretty strong
opponent um so yeah you get symmetric
positions with an open e fun in the
Petrov that's true but the thing is that
quite often there is some kind of
tension there because of the because of
the the piece placement it's not
necessarily boring all the time I
understand you're you're feeling it is
not as the complicated opening ever but
it is sometimes really am helpful that
the white players don't have a great
recipe against it is just the case then
they don't get it so often
whenever I prepare for people with my e5
and my ruler pants is black I always see
that they never get the Petrov and i
always think okay they're never ever
going to have something great in the
Petrov so yeah I played against this guy
when it was very funny in one of my my
regular blitz games and he overlooked a
win and resigned instead of just winning
it was kind of a funny situation really
it was very funny yeah okay I didn't
this game is rather boring after to
admit I we traded a little bit and it is
I think about equal it looks like that
my sea pony is a slight weakness but I
don't know how bad it is he here I was
thinking that c5 should be good let's do
that come on keep it simple trying to
trade this week pawn if he moves
something on the C file I can take the
six with the tech on the queen is this
this is not very exciting but he caught
me in an opening line that I don't know
a lot I'm studying this a bit for white
but I don't know yeah I can't play the
Petrov but every to know it I really
don't know it a lot but i think it's not
a bad idea to play it it's really not
especially if you want an open position
there are some lines that are not very
exciting that's true but you have an
exciting lines and other openings as
well yeah the exchange French maybe your
chiro can exchange or whatever okay okay
just he decided to just take which is
the simple decision here I really think
it should be totally equal or maybe can
I do something on the six pawn I don't
know probably not
maybe on the hacking go rox is seven but
this night maybe 94 looks good right
looking at ecigs and if he goes I five I
can take stick f5 at least after the
trade okay went down like here I me can
play you three actually okay Bishop f4
me5 I mean II five be sure before 94 95
should be possible though okay okay
let's use the C file it's this is equal
ish very equal ish but check egos root
g7 can try night a335 but it's probably
not leading too much maybe still the
relatively best chance I of course there
now we just controlled c7 I forgot about
that what can I do here can I do
something something at all I don't
really think so if I give the check he
goes to f6 hmm and he has rook be too
coming maybe it's just equal you can
it's it's very difficult to get anything
going here is threatening 93 now not
sure I mean kingi one looks kind of
weird okay i'm going to try but okay
here we go hmm
alright that's really nothing going on
let's let's just do let's just do them
let's just straight down and offer it
raw here it doesn't want to hit us kind
of funny winning with black is kind of
scanned over and now we offer to draw
himself yeah it's really nothing going
on he's 100 something favorite but this
this is totally drawn okay let's see um
any bad and not bad any commentary yeah
I had a good match against um against
curtains right Greg Shahadah it was just
one of those those cases where things
went my way it's just sometimes happens
in the first game if you if you saw that
in the first game I laid my pet line in
the Rhodope s that's not very good but
it I really know it really really well
and that was really good for me that I
got something that I know and in the
second game it was a very very normal
kind of thing and although the deform
Queens Indian opening and um yeah what
can you say him and what exactly is this
guy doing eight miles high hi you're
probably high on something GM you know
something okay a4 and stuff this is kind
of kind of funny look to h4 okay hmm ok
ok I'm just going to develop and see
what happens so if I guess
hmm I don't know there is probably some
kind of substances involved here yeah
i'm not sure what it is but some kind of
substance is involved it could be
alcohol it could be something something
something more but this is not looking
really good I mean let's see I can take
you three for winning probably winning a
pawn and the queen but queen to d6 is
also quite good ok let's let's just take
them it is um it should be quite ok and
let's say I mean this a a 4 h h4 stuff
is something that should be probably am
yeah unlimited 2 bullet chess if at all
I mean in bullet you can can do many
weird things but five minute I'm not
saying it's serious chest but it's kind
of a little bit more serious ok
threatens made on c2 and the bishop so
that's it yeah it's a bit too much but
thanks for the points um let's see any
many's anything here nope no serious
question yeah I'm really high in terms
of rating yeah it's nice 25 something is
my records here ok let's go my record in
Nam in on the chest explain account I
had a higher rating with a non
commentary account once but never got
above 25 6 60 70 or so ok so we play a
funny line in the Queen's engine
yeah play that guy more and get 25 yeah
maybe but I don't know we probably
already fell off his chair okay well
this is a this is an interesting line
yeah after taking on d 2 I got a nice
Bishop to e4 a very flexible position
this is kind of typical for the Queen's
Indian you're very flexible and solid so
let's see oh wow what is this guy doing
ha I did not think about this one each
takes or take them home ikik I'm taking
the Queen it's just a trade really
that's not a very exciting position I
guess when you get high end in the in
the rating department they probably
start to play for troughs more maybe
this guy is just wanting to trade stuff
and make a draw it looks a bit like that
okay maybe I can get to a position where
he he can put her that's not not really
okay I wonder if I'm even worse a little
bit here with bishops is 6 mm maybe but
the thing is he wants to trade
everything under the Sun they don't mind
it that much him to d5 maybe I'd like to
get my rook on the e-file but I don't
see any way to do it I can go night d 7
but then it probably takes her maybe
night to eat some
yeah that won't be easy
if you are really like 1,800 1,700 and
so on what you should do is study
opening principles looking at opening
sequences to try to get an idea how to
punish bad play because many of your
opponents will play bad moves in the
opening you should be able to exploit
that but learning um tons of moves like
concrete lines is really a bit too early
it's not helpful for you to learn a
complicated opening you should learn how
the things kind of work together let's
say but it's not necessary to study many
concrete lines okay what do we get here
we're going to get rooks traded as well
no maybe it's actually playing well that
could be rookie 7 look t-34 the rooks
swing okay so i should be ready for for
this okay interesting
hmm Jim maybe I can prepare c5 on this
position james might-- okay let's go see
five I can take our playbook 270 that's
stupid he can take c5 I forgot about
that I was only thinking of the hump on
Saul caption hmm and Addie take c5 this
good for him it's just good for white dt
XD takes Rupert e7 awful really awful
okay I probably have to oh it doesn't do
it it doesn't play it I don't know why
but he did not plan okay maybe here okay
hmm if I get rook straight up I'm very
okay but I don't know if I ever manage
that yeah tactics are far more important
for beginning players than any openings
that's really true okay my idea is to
play Knight to f5 and then establish the
knight on d4 here i'm also trying to
play we can play book to Selma the rook
trade is excellent for black quite
clearly so we won't trade rooks would be
very surprising okay maybe Bishop Pierce
is idea I don't know I go younger than
him activating the rook and maybe I can
get in King the 89 f 52 d 4 i'm also
checking this here on f2 not sure how is
going to defend against that
Bishop c6 is mostly a check and not much
more maybe I cannot take them on f 2
because of route d3 check and look 27
that's very much possible actually so
I'm just going back attacking the bishop
winning trying to win a pond so here I
can go here and night to deform alright
I'm going to do that go down and again
the rook trade I'm very okay with as his
pawns are all on light square so I don't
mind that at all okay I can also why can
i justjust go that night on d4 that
cannot be possibly bad okay what now
look f6 on probably this right for rook
to e7 try to force the rook trade okay
job here you know has to trade really I
think it looks very strange to move the
rook somewhere on the fourth-ranked we
had has almost no squares okay now i can
trade but i don't know if i should i
think i should it cannot be bad this end
game and it probably has some chances to
play for win so i want to check the pawn
down let's see c3 jfo it's not easy to
get in ok let's start like that
ok trying to fight for some squares here
and put more stuff that years andar on
light squares so I'm totally safe here
now can get the King here and now I have
to think about how I can i improve the
night can I somehow a check the porn i
can play night e 2 C 3 a form mmhmm if I
go nitey to King d3 my therefore check
it doesn't lead to much okay maybe you
start like this and if i go here nighty
too now maybe try to try to go there he
can go where I can do that I came in
okay have to go back now we can play h4
actually hmm I should have avoided that
one maybe I have no win that's it so
it's possible it looks very nice but
maybe I having a win but now I get to
the pawn right and I will take it not
sure that it wins though
Jeff this is a pawn a person ok after go
to 2d six and then be 5 may he lost some
time he lost some time it's probably a
draw probably a draw ok
I don't think that the advice to focus
on on on on tactics some form beginner
players or it is some it is helpful to
study opening principles you can study
openings by looking at games yeah if you
want if you look at like all the games
we're opening principles are violated
and they are punished let's say with a
direct attack in the in the early
opening this is something that is
helpful definitely and I don't abduct
object to that at all in fact if I have
fun players I mean I managed I match it
I am a chess teacher and they have some
people rated 1,200 1,300 1,400 and I
often look at Short games by strong
players like Ella kind morphy how they
punished weak opening play because this
is something that is some coming up all
the time even nowadays so it's it's very
useful to look at that it's not useful
to look at 20 moves off the poisoned
pawn night off this is in fact totally
ridiculous yeah so this is what I'm
trying to say you have to do the right
things with the openings if you focus on
on on middle games this kind of things
it is very very useful to do some okay
what is this guy doing actually he's
playing very very quickly and this is a
strange kind of tirage okay let's take
them and now hmm 91 2 d's let you want
to do three maybe it looks really
strange what black you did in this game
but he's playing in an instant I really
love those people playing instant moves
and then they have a crap position and
they start to think and think and think
and all of a sudden they recognized oh
wow this isn't any good okay I don't
know how bad this is but it's not great
let's see you see threatening to take it
to maybe
can take c6 and d6 I don't like to give
up my bishop against this kind of place
obviously just playing form yeah kind of
a short move tactics or things like that
but okay it's probably still right to do
so okay if I can I take you there I
can't take that right snow is not to but
I have to be circumspect it's probably
as mentioned playing for some tactics
okay if I give the check here he has to
go to has to go to age eight neither
three is not really great not so easy i
can i can give a ton of checks of course
but it's not leading to much I can
repeat moves them okay probably 92 okay
just takes this is surprising now he's
just a pawn down for nothing i was
thinking he was trying to play I'm play
on my somewhat weakened my son would
weekend king position yeah this is the
last game this is the last game I didn't
watch the clock actually when I started
the game and this is actually a little
bit longer than we planned for okay it's
not easy to to play for winning this
position he has good chances to escape
to an end game a pawn down that is
horrible rook be five maybe as
yeah it's and rookie aid was my idea
buddy has a 5 first and this is some a
bit awkward so there any way to do
something probably not yet and they have
to be a bit alert because he's very
quick so what is this move yeah you can
do that it's nothing nothing special
there's no way to I don't think there's
a way to play for winning this position
pretty difficult I is offer me a draw
I'm taking that he's two minutes up I
mean it's kind of it's kind of painful
because he just dashed out any any kind
of move without much consideration and I
should really win the game but I'm kind
of kind of medicine stick that look him
look there I don't really want to check
briefly we're screwed that up maybe I
shouldn't have played Queen a free maybe
queena three was a stupid decision I
have the better King here somewhere it's
also Queenie for yeah maybe maybe this
is still more precise I don't know I
should have fun I should have gotten
gotten more of that okay um let's see
where are we any big question how do we
many many questions um there's a
question have i given up on the
Kalashnikov um no I just play it once
once in a while um and I don't know I
tend tend to play all kinds of all kinds
of openings and I think the Kalashnikov
is very decent um but the problem is
that i like time to study really a lag
time and it's an opening where you want
to know some lines I mean it's possible
to make it up as you go along but I'm
not familiar with it I like the book or
not the killer the sodium but it's
something that I looked at some lines
but I didn't really I mean I would be
need to if to make it playable on a good
level for me or playable something word
if I feel that I feel confident to play
it I would need to invest really tons of
hours and
it's a it's not the time that I have at
the moment um there's a question will i
post the spanish opening series to
youtube no I I did record that for the
mentioned a competitive platform and
it's only accessible in there in the
area in the premium area them when it
will be released but as mentioned i will
also do if you are an icc member there
is some of you an icc member there is
also the there will be videos coming up
then i will do for eyes to see as well
okay i hope you enjoyed the broadcast it
was a little bit longer than the one
hour I know it was enjoyable actually
won a couple of points this is this is
nice and it's just really high rating I
need to be cautious there okay well
thanks a lot for watching and I'll be
back next week I guess next week the
same Monday okay till then um where is
it here